[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans votre 7,8 week-end voici les titres
de ce vendredi 19 mars un confinement 7
jours sur 7 c'est ce qu'a annoncé le
premier ministre jean castex jeudi soir
16 départements dont les yvelines sont
concernés nous parlerons de ce troisième
confinement avec nos deux invités et
didier baichère député des yvelines et
fabien le duigou du syndicat snes fsu 78
l'actualité c'est aussi la visite de
gérard larcher président du sénat au
centre de vaccination de rambouillet ce
vendredi retour sur ce déplacement enfin
comme chaque semaine ses liens guettent
son goût vous proposera ses idées
sorties et loisirs
mais
[Applaudissements]
cette fois ci nous y sommes le premier
ministre l'a annoncé jeudi soir un
confinement 7 jours sur 7 pour 16
départements les yvelines tout comme
l'ensemble de l'île de france sont
concernés
ce troisième confinement et le début de
ce vendredi 19 mars minuit et doit durer
quatre semaines minimum
d'abord le confinement n'annule pas le
couvre-feu il passe tout de même de 18h
à 19h pour s'adapter à l'heure d'été
ensuite ce qui change pour les
territoires concernés les déplacements
entre régions sont interdits les
commerces non essentiels sont fermées
sauf les librairies et les coiffeurs
désormais est essentielle en revanche
les écoles les collèges restent ouverts
tout comme les commerces alimentaires et
courses de première nécessité enfin les
sorties sont autorisés que ce soit pour
s'aérer se promener ou faire du sport
mais uniquement dans un rayon de 10 km
autour de chez soi sans limite de temps
toutefois et avant d'accueillir notre
invité on écoute quelques réactions des
élus yvelinois recueillies par les
journalistes de la rédaction de tv 78 on
était vraiment cette fois-ci consulter
qu'elle est peut-être la première fois
que ça se passait comme ça savez j'ai
tapé un peu du poing sur la table ça ne
pouvait pas durer tout veut pas se
décider en conseil de défense
on en a maintenant pour quatre semaines
en ile de france en même temps il faut
faire preuve d'une solidarité parce que
les équipes en réa et sont aujourd'hui
incroyablement sollicité que ce soit
l'hôpital public que ce soit à l'hôpital
privé il faut avoir une pensée pour tous
ceux là c'est un confinement sans être
un confinement puisqu'on a droit de
faire quasiment ce qu'on veut sauf
malheureusement pour les commerces non
essentiels mais quasiment ce qu'on veut
sur un périmètre de 10 km
on repousse le couvre-feu de 18h à 19h
une époque on disait qu'il fallait être
enfermé aujourd'hui qu'il fallait qu'il
faut être dehors un peu abattu un c'est
vrai que s'il n'y avait pas eu autant de
louper sur la vaccination
on aurait peut-être pu s'éviter seront
confinement qui n'en est pas un puisque
garde quand même une certaine souplesse
voilà donc moi pas de polémique on
avance
le département sera présent trois qu'on
a pris à tous pris un coup sur la tête
même si on pouvait s'y attendre vu les
chiffres
après j'ai peur moi que ce soit encore
un peu des demi-mesures en fait parce
que
le télétravail est encouragée mais pas
forcément obligatoire que les écoles
restent ouvertes je trouve ça
extrêmement c'est très bien et je pense
qu'il faut que les enfants aillent à
l'école pour parler de ce confinement
sept jours sur sept dans les yvelines et
dans 15 autres départements nous
accueillons avec mon plateau didier
baichère bonsoir vous êtes je le
rappelle le député la république en
marge de la première circonscription des
yvelines
tout d'abord on l'a entendu que
répondez-vous aux élus qui ont qui se
sont exprimés sur ce confinement
je vois globalement on est sur une forme
de cohésion sur le territoire puisque
c'est vrai qu'il ya sur le plan
sanitaire il faut le dire un travail qui
est fait coordonné par le préfet des
yvelines avec la rs et l'ensemble des
élus locaux les particulièrement les
présidents et d'agglomération et les
maires les maires des villes et c'est
vrai que ça se passe plutôt bien dans
les yvelines donc on le sent dans le
dans les commentaires maintenant
personne est ravi ce nouvel épisode de
confinement très rapidement on a on a
quand même eu trois phases qui sont
assez compliqué on a eu ce mois de
janvier avec une croissance qui était
plutôt molle du nombre de cas un plateau
en février on a eu un vrai plateau au
mois de février je pense les premiers
effets de la vaccination et puis on a 30
% d'augmentation les quinze premiers
jours de mars avec cette accélération
due aux variants anglais qui prend tout
le monde de court et qui fait que sur le
plan sanitaire on est obligé d'écouter
les soignants on est obligé de faire le
constat de la saturation de des lits de
réanimation dans les yvelines et en ile
de france qui a conduit à cette décision
hier soir et donc on se retrouve avec un
confinement 7 jours sur 7 pour les
yvelines et puis évidemment 16 autres
départements moins strictes qu'en mars
dernier on l'a compris aussi est-ce que
c'est un aveu d'échec le fait de
reconfirmer pour le gouvernement
et pensez vous que les yvelinois vont
l'accepter je pense que tout le monde en
a assez 1 depuis douze mois c'est vrai
que c'est difficile
encore une fois je pense que ces
variants c'est mutation de virus sont
compliquées il n'y a que la vaccination
qui nous permettra de sortir de cette
situation
fermer quand même évité se confie bien
sûr c'est ce qu'on a vu d'ailleurs
souvenez vous quand le président de la
république après cette décision fin
janvier on a bien vu d'ailleurs en
février qui a eu ce plateau
malheureusement et c'est 80% des cas
maintenant c'est le variant angles
en fait qui a mis la pagaille moi je
pense qu'on peut pas faire de paris sur
la santé des français et des yvelinois
voilà on a écouté les soignants on sait
la capacité de nos hôpitaux il ya une
croissance de 30 % des lits en
réanimation en ile de france donc c'est
une progression qui étaient importantes
au cours de ces derniers mois
voilà maintenant il ya plus de place il
faut absolument casser la chaîne de
progression du virus et on s'est même si
ce confinement on va pouvoir aller à
l'extérieur effectivement parce qu'on
s'est rendu compte aussi calé à
l'extérieur c'était pas forcément
dangereux
par contre il faut qu'on évite coûte que
coûte de se croiser dans les magasins on
l'a on l'avait vu précédemment avec la
fermeture des grands centres commerciaux
et justement nous allons y revenir les
commerces dits non essentiels vont
fermer leurs portes ce vendredi 19 mars
minuit mais les libraires les coiffeurs
par exemple qui n'étaient pas des
commerces essentiel en novembre dernier
le sont aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'on ne s'y perd pas un peu
est-ce qu'il ya d'autres commerces qui
vont rejoindre ces commerces dits
essentiels
et surtout qu'est ce que cela change ce
avec le 2ème confinant comparé à ce que
ce deuxième continent
en fait c'est des enseignements des deux
premiers confinement si vous vous
souvenez ce qui s'était passé en
particulier sur le premier confinement
on s'était rendu compte que la fermeture
des coiffeurs par exemple qui avait mis
en place un protocole sanitaire
extrêmement strictes n'était pas
nécessaire là les libraires aussi et là
on est aussi dans la considération de
l'état psychologique après un an il faut
aussi être en capacité de pouvoir aller
chercher de la lecture pouvoir peut-être
se faire plaisir en se faisant couper
les cheveux à un moment donné c'est
aussi ça c'est 706 sensibilité je pense
à l'état psychologique qui fait que sur
des commerces qui peuvent donner du
bonheur quelque part c'est quand on va
acheter un livre où quand on va chez le
coiffeur on est on est aussi dans un
moment de détente et c'est ça qui a
voulu être soulignée par cette ouverture
est ce que d'autres professions les
auto-écoles je pense particulièrement à
cette profession vont pas c'est
essentiel on verra là dans deux dans les
jours qui viennent parce que vous vous
doutez bien qu'il ya énormément de
discussion il faut aussi que la machine
ne s'arrête pas complètement donc il
continue à y avoir un certain nombre de
discussions et puis les préfets pendant
un certains nombre d'arrêtés aussi de
particuliers souvent jeu suivant les
départements mais ce qu'il faut retenir
c'est la règle on ne contraint pas par
rapport à la ville à la fin se promener
à l'extérieur là quand on est dehors qui
a de la place qui est de l'espace on
peut on peut sortir
on ne va pas dans les magasins sauf si
on doit faire ses courses pour manger et
c'est tout et c'est encore une fois ce
confinement aussi un appel à la
responsabilité collective
on le fait pour nos soignants pour que
l'hôpital n'explose pas mais il faut
aussi casser collectivement et
comprendre qu'on a besoin casser la
progression du variant anglais va qu'on
voit progresser encore une fois de 30%
par an 30 % pardon ces quinze derniers
jours sur sur le département de l'île de
france
et j'imagine que cela passe aussi par la
vaccination dernière question le
gouvernement a promis l'accélération de
la vaccination
une nouvelle fois le vaccin est rennaise
unique ajustements dans l'actualité peut
de nouveau être injectés depuis ce
vendredi après midi
va-t-il y avoir de nouveaux centres de
vaccination en particulier dans les
yvelines
mais également est-ce que des
professionnels comme les infirmières à
domicile et social libéral vont-elles
pouvoir elles aussi vacciner lors des
décrets sont passés déjà pour que les
pharmaciens puissent vacciner
donc c'est la prochaine étape de
vaccination avec le retour de
d'astrazeneca qui fait que les vaccins
et les médecins généralistes vont
pouvoir vacciner il a progressivement
des centres qui ouvre dans les villes
des yvelines on le voit sur sur saint
quentin en yvelines
le centre qu'ovide du vélodrome va
doubler sa capacité on va passer à 2000
vaccinations par jour en possibilités
donc il ya une vraie accélération on a
vu les deux derniers week-ends élus 2000
vaccination qui ont été faits sur sur 50
ans c'est l'accélération elle est là et
encore une fois je pense que on le voit
bien dans les déclarations que les élus
du département ont fait tout à l'heure
au début de votre reportage
on est vraiment tous concentrés sur la
situation sanitaire il faut vacciner le
plus rapidement possible pour tenir cet
objectif des 10 millions de français
vaccinés au mois de mai puis 20 milles
puis trente mille pour que cet été voilà
l'histoire du virus on l'espère tous
soient vraiment derrière nous on
l'espère en effet merci didier baichère
député la république en marge de la
première circonscription des yvelines
d'avoir été avec nous sur ce plateau du
sud ce week end
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
l'actualité c'est aussi la visite du
président du sénat dans les yvelines
gérard larcher s'est rendu ce vendredi
19 mars au centre de vaccination de
rambouillet il est venu constater
l'avancée de la vaccination
reportage de grégory canal et depuis le
18 janvier la salle patenôtre de
rambouillet s'est transformé en un
centre de vaccination
elle fait partie des 13 sites désormais
effective dans le département ce
vendredi 19 mars le président du sénat
gérard larcher a rencontré sur place les
acteurs de terrain l'objectif faire le
bilan de deux mois de campagne de
vaccination dans le sud yvelines
premier constat qui n'avaient pas les
collectivités territoriales ci avait pas
les professionnels de santé
s'il y avait pas un centre hospitalier
on voit bien que ce qui se passe ici ne
serait pas possible j'y ajoute les
bénévoles à rambouillet plus de 5000
personnes ont pu être vaccinés
mais les élus locaux souhaitent que la
campagne s'accélère davantage nous le
savons la vaccination est le moyen le
plus certain pour éradiquer ce virus est
que nous avons besoin d'être entendus
pour assouplir la façon de vacciner de
façon à pouvoir vacciner en masse
c'est la tante de la population et ça
nous l'entendons tous les jours ce que
j'ai retenu ce matin c'est que si on ne
change pas si on ne fait pas évoluer la
méthode nous n'atteindrons pas
l'objectif que d'ailleurs le président
de la république a fixés
je pense que c'est un objectif que nous
devons avoir en partage le gouvernement
s'est fixé comme objectif d'atteindre 30
millions de personnes vaccinées à l'été
dans le département plus de 96 milles
yvelinois ont reçu une première
injection pour continuer à parler des
nouvelles annonces du gouvernement et de
ce confinement sept jours sur sept nous
accueillons notre deuxième invitée chez
en visioconférence avec nous fabien le
duigou bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes co
secrétaire au sein du syndicat scolaire
snes fsu dans les yvelines
tout d'abord je le rappelle les
établissements scolaires écoles au
collège reste ouvert ce sont les
nouvelles annonces comment avez-vous
réagi justement à ces nouvelles annonces
est ce que c'est un soulagement une
inquiétude supplémentaire alors c'est
davantage une inquiétude puisque on nous
dit que la pandémie s'accélère la
situation se dégrade
on a eu un sèche et c'était d'ailleurs
dans les yvelines jeudi et les chiffres
qu'on nous annonce et sont pas très bon
il ya eu soixante trois classes et trois
établissements qui ont été fermés
quatorze classes actuellement enfin
mardi dernier qui était fermé et on
allonge donc d à peu près entre 120 et
150 cas positifs par jour dans les
établissements scolaires donc non c'est
plutôt l'inquiétude du fait qu' un pas
que les écoles et collèges restent
ouverts ça c'est un soulagement on a
toujours défendu l'ouverture des
établissements
par contre le fait qu'il n'y ait pas de
renforcement des protocoles sanitaires
ça c'est inquiétant et justement l'autre
annonce concernant la scolarité ce sont
les lycées qui doivent désormais
obligatoirement passer en demies jauge
que pensez vous de cette annonce
alors j'ai un côté positif c'est
qu'enfin on a droit à un cadrage
national ça fait depuis le début de
l'année qu'on demande à un cadrage
national sur les aménagements
d'organisation des enseignes des
enseignements pour rappel dans les
lycées
depuis le mois de novembre et ça c'est
ça on a réussi à l'obtenir par des
lutins des ludique et des collègues
engrais etc
c'était la possibilité pour les
proviseurs de lycées d'aménager
effectivement l'enseignement en passant
en demi groupe soit semaine en semaine 2
soit matin après midi
mais en fait c'est des chefs
d'établissement qui avait la possibilité
de le faire
en fait il y avait beaucoup d inégalité
entre lycées puisque certains lycées
étaient en 100% présentiel alors que
d'autres avaient aménagé des
renseignements hybrides depuis le mois
de janvier surtout au mois de mars
encourager d'ailleurs par la direction
académique des yvelines les chefs
d'établissement voulais revenir en fait
on 100% présentiel quelquefois
d'ailleurs sans consulter les personnels
sont faire un vote aussi ou moins là il
ya un cadrage national après
concrètement sais pas ce qui va se
passer on va évoquer quand même la
dernière annonce sur l'éducation
physique et sportive sur le temps
scolaire jean castex a déclaré que ça
pourrait reprendre normalement
qu'est ce que vous en pensez de cette
annonce et comment vous allez vous
organiser alors dans les lycées alors
normalement ça veut dire que désormais
les courts du ps aussi avoir lieu en
milieu fermé dans les gymnases par
exemple on sait que depuis effectivement
que les profs de ps devait faire
uniquement leurs cours en extérieur est
appliquée parce que clairement il n'y
avait pas forcément les infrastructures
n'est suffisant pour accueillir tous les
élèves donc dans les lycées qui seront
en 2012 qu'en 2000 groupe
je pense que ça sera faisable est
possible mais dans les collèges des
coupes à 30 du 30 élèves enfermés dans
les gymnases
je suis pas sûr que les protocoles
tenons vraiment à être respecté mon
collègue inquiétudes sur les collèges
est derrière nous ce qu'on regrette
c'est que il est seulement les lycées
qui est qu'ils aient eu cette
possibilité dans cette obligation de
passer en 2011
il aurait fallu aussi que les collèges
et puis savoir 7,7 modalités
d'organisation des enseignements merci
fabien le du goût d'avoir été avec nous
par visioconférence je rappelle que vous
êtes le co secrétaire au sein du quinze
ans syndicat snes fsu pardon dans le 78
merci on change de sujet à présent
malgré le confinement qui entre en
vigueur ce vendredi soir s'il ya 400 go
vous propose ses idées sorties et
loisirs qui reste possible pour ce week
end
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette semaine nous allons essayer de
vous faire un peu rêver surtout en cette
période où on en a bien besoin
à 32 ans mehdi ait el hocine veut faire
de sa passion son métier et se monte
soneva obtenir un bac plus de magie un
diplôme très sérieux ans puisqu'il est
reconnu par l'état depuis 2018 un
montage de l'uqar buts de lucas godard
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
au pire
ce tour de magie mehdi ait el hocine le
connais depuis longtemps
ce jeune homme de 32 ans est magicien
semi professionnel dans quelques mois il
obtiendra un diplôme niveau bac + 2
reconnu par l'état depuis 2018
c'est un plus pour le client ce genre
ami lullin du pommeau de mazet ça il est
reconnu en tant qu en 3 et ses impros
l'école de magie se trouve au double
fond un café théâtre du 4e
arrondissement de paris les professeurs
de magie retravaille les tours avec
leurs élèves jusqu'à ce qu'il soit
parfait pour l'instant médias et el
hocine est chargée de mission pour les
établissements scolaires pour la mairie
de rueil malmaison dans les hauts de
seine
en parallèle il travaille à la création
du spectacle un spectacle adulte on a
allié l'impro et la magie c'est vraiment
super qu'on a travaillé j'ai beaucoup de
spectacle possible pour enfants sur les
5,6 donc j'ai pas mal de choses qui sont
prêtes et qui demande qui demande du
public
valentin j'ai retrouvé ton des eaux
merci mais non c'est pas mon des gens
n'est pas tombé une banane dans le sac
avantageux pose de sacchi si ça dérange
pas et on prend sept aps ça recommence
attendez
[Musique]
transformée dans le sac
une fois magicien professionnel média et
lots s'il aimerait proposer des
spectacles de magie autour du bien vivre
ensemble que ce soit le harcèlement
scolaire ou l'échec scolaire ou aussi
tout ce qui est tout ce que sur la
personne comme l'homophobie sur beaucoup
de sujets assez dur maître de la magie
dedans pour faire passer un message aux
jeunes pour l'instant les spectacles de
se monter sonné sont à l'arrêt le temps
de la crise sanitaire
inoffensif pour l'environnement les
produits ménagers merlin ont été
inventés par un versailles et sous forme
de sachets il ya seulement quatre
ingrédients de dans le principe dit lui
les actifs avec de l'eau les images de
justin brasier intentions actif du
carbonate de sodium du citrate de sodium
et des huiles essentielles quatre
ingrédients pour fabriquer un produit
ménager dégraissant merlin le prête à
frotter écologique a été créé par un
versailles et il se présente sous forme
de sachets contenant des principes
actifs en poudre à diluer chez soi il
suffit de deux cuillères à café de ces
principes actifs
mélanger à 500 1000 et du taux et de ce
cui berlin c'est l'idée de changer un
peu la donne sur les premiers entretiens
aujourd'hui un produit d'entretien
classique c
kudo et puis avec des substances qui
sont parfois dangereuses ou qui est de
changer la donne et dire allons à
l'essentiel ne vendons que les actifs
sous la forme d'une poudre le format le
plus pur possible que l'on dit lui à la
maison
ajoutez à cela les principes actifs sont
vendus dans un mini sachet en vrac
recyclables et 80 % des ingrédients sont
issus de la valorisation des biodéchets
cet ancien salarié remarketing à une
prise de conscience lors d'une
expérience de volontariat haïti là bas
il fallait gérer nous mêmes nos déchets
donc forcément quand on gère somme ces
déchets mais on se pose tous la question
j'achète ce produit là qu'est ce que je
vais en faire une fois que ça sera
terminé de ça forcément quand on a on
est rentré j'ai eu envie d'agir de
contribuer par parce que je faisais et
d'abord par en changeant la consommation
réduire l'impact écologique en achetant
français et en utilisant des matières
renouvelables
voilà l'idée du produit la marque merlin
on n'est pas encore commercialisé mais
maxime giroux a créé une campagne de
financement participative sur ulule et
après la campagne sera disponible en
e-commerce et j'espère très vite dans
les boutiques bio plus fondateur de
merlin participants parallèle au
concours de la fabrique aviva dont il a
passé la première phase la deuxième se
tiendra le 23 mars prochain
objectif récolter 60 mille euros on en
parlait déjà en décembre les jeux de
société font leur grand retour sur les
tables des yvelinois c'est la tombe bien
puisque une boutique de jeux de société
va bientôt ouvrir dans les prochains
mois à montigny le bretonneux kevin abd
ar men doit de bonsoir vous êtes le
giron du coût de cette nouvelle boutique
qui s'appellera des rires et des jeux en
ce moment vous bénéficiez d'une campagne
participative de financement sur game en
dble top vous avez collecté plus de 5900
euros
combien d'argent il vous faudrait pour
ouvrir la boutique sereinement
j'ai quand même réussi à acquérir
suffisamment de fonds pour pouvoir
ouvrir la boutique maintenant c'est vrai
que pour être vraiment serein il
faudrait qu'on réussisse à collecter un
petit peu plus on va dire ben voila si
on arrive à atteindre les 8000 euros on
devrait déjà être un peu plus tranquille
et réussir à ouvrir assez sereinement et
voit revenir les
mais moi vous compte à ouvrir bientôt
dans mois d'avril mois de mai la date
exacte si vous l'aviez c'est tout se
passe bien on pourrait ouvrir
normalement fin avril début mai c'est
vrai que j'aurais aimé pouvoir ouvrir
plus tôt malheureusement on a eu
quelques petits imprévus quelques
petites choses aulaqi mais qui ne qui
n'était pas prévu au programme et qui
finalement nous prend un petit peu de
retard mais bon normalement on devrait
réussir à ouvrir dans le mans fabre dans
votre boutique
il y aura peu près combien de jeux de
société disponible à la vente alors dans
la boutique qui aura plus de 1500
références sachant que ça ira aussi bien
du jeu de société classique en allant
jusqu'aux jeux de figurines aux jeux de
cartes et également au jeu de rôle
papier comme donjons et dragons par
exemple l'industrie du jeu attire quel
type de public finalement qui va bien
dans votre boutique
c'est quoi un moment on avait un public
qui était assez restreint star que
public de niche mais de plus en plus
grâce heures grâce au lac au vide entre
guillemets le public en fait s'est
intéressé au nouveau jeu et on a un
public beaucoup plus large
comment savoir vraiment le grand public
qui s'intéresse beaucoup plus même au
jeu de rôle par exemple qui était
vraiment énormément ciblées aujourd'hui
on a vraiment tout un public beaucoup
plus important qui j'ai qui se dirigent
vers les jeux et même si avant on était
vraiment sur des gens qu'il est très
spécialisé maintenant je pense qu'on
peut avoir un pic qui est beaucoup plus
néophytes peut-être dans les jeux les
experts est plus possible et pourquoi
ouvrir une boutique dans montigny à
montigny le bretonneux
parce que je me suis dit qu'il y avait
des étudiants que c'était peut-être
intéressant d'aller toucher un peu cette
cible est plus j'ai creusé plus je me
suis rendu compte qu'en fait il y avait
1-1 public autour il y avait des clubs
qui justement sont très demandeurs qui
aujourd'hui n'ont pas trop le choix il
doit aller soit versailles soit sur
paris et c'est vrai que d'avoir une
boutique à la plus proche de chez eux ça
leur ferait bien plaisir
c'est pas un pari risqué on peut
d'ouvrir une boutique en fait une crise
sanitaire sort était un pari extrêmement
risquée si je n'avais fait qu'une
boutique fille
zik mais j'ai fait le choix de faire en
plus une boutique en ligne avec un petit
service supplémentaire un service de
livraison à domicile qui sera fait par
mail soit en soirée donc c'est quelque
chose qui je pense peut avoir une plus
value et qui peut intéresser les gens
surtout que cette crise sanitaire même
si elle pose de quelques soucis à pour
le commerce
pour ce qui est des jeux en l'occurrence
la tendance plutôt à pas mal aidé dans
le sens où les gens ont énormément de
temps tu sois avec les premiers
confinement qu'on a eus ou avec le
couvre-feu les gens plus de temps et se
retrouvent pour plus souvent autour
d'une table et ont besoin justement de
jeu pour pouvoir rêver pouvoir essayer
de supporter un peu cette situation qui
est quand même très difficile à vivre
pour nous tous on va parler un peu de
vous vous étiez chef de projet pourquoi
finalement mais devenir gérant d'une
boutique de jeux de société ça faisait
ça fait déjà 10 ans en fait que je rêve
d'ouvrir ma propre boutique de jeux de
société c'est vrai que pendant un moment
je ne pensais pas être capable parce que
je n'ai pas forcément les compétences
parce que je n'ai pas forcément les
moyens et finalement au bout de dix ans
dix ans à réfléchir à rêver je pense que
le confinement m'a pas mal aidé le
premier confinement qu'est ce qui lui a
permis de réfléchir de me dire que
aujourd'hui j'ai 30 ans je n'ai pas
encore de famille je n'ai pas encore
manque de responsabilité vis-à-vis
d'enfants ou autres et je suis donc
beaucoup plus libre de pouvoir prendre
du temps pour faire ça et aujourd'hui
j'ai plus de compétences chez plus de
moyens donc je me suis dit c'est
vraiment le moment pour me lancer
c'est un moment aussi qui comme j'ai dit
est plutôt utile pour les jeux qui pour
le moment lors leur réussit plutôt pas
mal donc pour moi c'était vraiment le
moment qu'il fallait choisir pour
pouvoir se lancer
et quel est votre jeu de société a
préféré ça c'est une très vaste question
serait compliqué d'y répondre mais je
dirais que en terme de jeu société
vraiment à proprement parler je suis
très tournée vers seven wonders duel qui
est un jeu qui permet de s'opposer
donc à une autre personne et qui demande
énormément de réflexion qui demande de
qui demande beaucoup de concentration
parce qu'il faut aussi regarder ce que
fait l'adversaire il faut réagir en
fonction de lui
et sinon si on se trouve plus dans les
jeux de rôle parce que j'ai une grosse
passion pour les jeux de rôle je dirais
que c'est le jeune ait qui est un jeu
qui propulse les gens dans un monde
apocalyptique dans lequel ils vont
devoir incarner des chevaliers les
armures high tech pour pouvoir lutter
contre les ténèbres et c'est assez
extraordinaire avis très épique
merci beaucoup kevin oermingen d'avoir
été notre invité merci m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est déjà la fin de votre 7,8 week-end
merci de l'avoir suivi et même confiné
je vous souhaite un très bon week-end et
une très belle soirée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]